because my tone is like i'm like but i'm
hurt because of this and it
automatically goes
yeah it's one of the biggest things he's
like stop yelling i'm like yeah
[Music]
hello everyone welcome back to big mood
today we have a very beautiful gorgeous
spectacular special guest named jess
lazama hi guys my favorite hey hi
she's awesome long long time friend you
know what i feel really sorry for you
guys because you can't smell her smells
amazing not only is she
gorgeous to look at she's gorgeous to
smell every time i hug her i go oh you
guys i love you you're like outside of
youth yeah because you never age she
ages backwards
she's younger than when i met her
like i'm her mom now well when you let
in with you guys you're lucky out there
because you can't smell her i'm like oh
where's this going did i oh yeah natural
deodorant that's what happened
we also have another special guest uh
michaeli with a w my name is michaeli
it's spelled m a
[Music]
describe what you're looking like right
now what do i look like you look like
where you're from very texan i've got a
double denim on because you know jesus
loves double denim and i've got a nice
little uh
the higher the hat the hair that's your
god yeah yeah mr god yes you're very
yeehaw you're just missing the boots i
am absolute yeehaw to the max today i
offered boots
she said no yeah
i'm good though but yeah no this is jess
and nikki yeah i got these clothes from
nikki's closet and just because i'm i'm
like so white it like makes me look so
connected it works so well yeah like you
have to wear that
style but i'm accepting it for this it
will be now in this video only yeah also
had to give her another name because we
have two dresses now so yeah true yeah
i can change my name too to whatever you
want it to be oh you know we actually
have uh like we started this thing
within our group where we are now
calling you lazama oh i love it yeah
yeah
because then we'll get you guys confused
and also there's another nick blade yeah
we're calling her blades now within our
group because then we're going to get
confused like there's two nicki's
intentions
yes i'm coming to set like
i'm right here guys my in my home yeah
yeah so nikki's here too and so is me
and tiff tiff so is that pregnant with
me
so is the baby
gina but she's here she's just not here
yeah also give great hugs and smells
amazing yes very true yes gina is
amazing okay well today though we're
going to be talking about uh the things
that people are sharing that are common
things that kill relationships
so just being yourself yeah so
we can
things that kill common mistakes in
relationships
being a man being a man
[Laughter]
oh these are great inside jokes for the
show
but yeah so the question was posed on
reddit and it said what are common
mistakes people make in a relationship
and the first one we have here it says
trying too hard to avoid potential
arguments to avoid conflict rather than
hashing it out before the issue becomes
too big to handle holy [ __ ]
this is true being too accommodating
because resentment
builds if you do that if you don't
address things right away you end up
building resentment even if you think
like no i just let things roll over my
shoulder no you don't yeah they're cool
everything's cool yeah i'm not crazy
you're crazy suppressing emotion doesn't
make them go away and then what happens
is you just end up eroding the passion
that you have for that relationship
exactly also too when you all you do is
accommodate the other person and you
agree with them all the time eventually
the real you has to come out and they're
just like who have i been dating for the
last four years like excuse me yes oh
you were you had your assistant in
that is the most relatable thing ever
big mistake what if what did you do can
i put you on the spot honey sure can i
please sorry okay i'm sorry but this was
literally casey to the t like to the
[ __ ] team he would accommodate
everything like still like we're working
on it because he still does that a lot
but like it seems like it comes from a
good place no definitely it's good logic
sounds
good but yes but it had been like so
we've been together almost 10 years like
nine and a half and for the first seven
and a half years of our entire
relationship i was i didn't know who he
really was because he would always just
show me like oh he would be a yes man
like people pleaser like whatever you
want to do sure whatever happy life yeah
and just do it but it was so frustrating
because then he would be brewing and
like like he'll be upset about something
that he or he told me to my face that
was fine but then he would like keep it
in and like hold resentment and like
it'll bleed in other ways and like he'll
like it would be like a volcano and then
he'll erupt over some other thing
and then uh no not word vomit like anger
vomit no anger vomit
anger bursts
and that was like a huge thing that just
like was killing the relationship and
i'm like
we can't get anywhere if you're not
honest with yourself if you're not
honest with me if you don't communicate
and then luckily therapy saved this
relationship because holy crap it was
going down the drain yeah and some
people are just crazy and that was just
one of many problems by the way right
like i don't think it's malicious like
it's it's like one
fighting bad fighting causes conflict
then it like hurt feelings and like
let's avoid it and then two another
reason people don't do it don't like
address things is because they
like don't know how to communicate yeah
it's also the way like people get raised
too yeah if you don't see that as an
example
around you at all with at all like for
anything then you don't even realize
like oh that's something that's needed
because then you just think it's normal
like sometimes yeah things will bother
stephen he's like well i didn't want to
sound like a little [ __ ] you know i'm
like no just like address it there and
we can solve it and then you don't have
to like and then i can say you're not a
little bit yeah and you're not a little
[ __ ] like if it bothers you you
shouldn't have to just stick with it
just because like if there's an easy
solution
actually kind of more of a little thing
to like be afraid to say what's on your
mind
even if it's minuscule yeah i mean i
think i can understand how in his head
he's like well it's so minor i don't
want to cause a fuss about it you know
that kind of thing but
um but it ends up like you said bleeding
out in other areas where it's like then
later he's just annoyed for no reason he
doesn't even know why
it's just because like earlier he
suppressed that it's gonna come out
somewhere feelings don't just go away
they come out somewhere yeah in my first
relationship i was ultra accommodating
and not that this is casey at all but i
also just didn't know myself so
everything that he wanted to do i was
just like yeah totally into it i just
didn't have an opinion so then when i
started to develop my own opinion it's
like okay well where did this girl come
from yeah and where has she been
when you did were you kind of were you
scared that that would scare him away i
was afraid of
yeah a little bit of like
oh me having an opinion that's outside
of yours could be bad and like this is
going to cause conflict and we're going
to argue over and i don't want to fight
but did he create that environment
though because i mean why did you feel
that way oh for sure like this was a
very um emotionally physically uh
abusive mentally abusive relationship so
i think in all ways and it doesn't start
that way right like it starts very
subtle and it's not like me looking back
as like this 40 year old woman where i
can say now like i'm super strong i
would never let that happen to me i
could absolutely see how
young women young people in general can
not even you could be a really strong
woman and that can still happen to you
yeah because it's such a subtle thing
you know and it moves slowly and moves
so slowly especially if you've never had
that experience before so you just
assume everyone is like it's normal
you've already met and so
like and then you trust this person and
you love them and like obviously they're
gonna have your back so if they're
saying you're doing something wrong then
it starts you know slowly escalating to
where you question your own job and it
builds so much shame yeah so now you
just feel ashamed and so with shame kind
of creates that silence you know so i
just kind of became ultra submissive and
ultra silent and i don't even know how
that happened
yeah i can't picture you
there's so much personality like i can't
picture it like
silent rage
so much rage
do you think like a maybe parenting
styles creates that in a person like
maybe for casey like he was never really
allowed to tell his parents what he
really felt so he had to be super
accommodating
perhaps to his parents and so that's
just how he's always dealt with conflict
was to never really bring anything up
like do you think maybe that family no
deadline
like through therapy
we explore that topic because like his
dad has a really strong personality and
like really strong opinionated strongly
opinionated and his mom is is the casey
like really accommodating for the most
part um
will just be like okay he said like okay
we'll do that or whatever it is
and you know how they say like you tend
to find partners that are similar to
your parents yeah yeah i'm his dad in
our relationship and in a lot of aspects
where i do have like a strong opinion
about something or i'll voice my
thoughts and so like you're explaining
your your experience jess and
yeah i could see how like i have
contributed to that behavior too but
it's also kind of like that's where he
finds comfort because that's what he
grew up in yeah and like we find our our
own
parents within our partners kind of
thing
and you have to recognize when it's like
unhealthy yeah so then you should sorry
yeah
i'm just like excited about yeah
yeah like exactly like i will find
moments like just recently there and
this is like so minor like so stupid but
just recently um we were i was gonna
pick up some food to go home and i was
like okay what do you want there's in
and out chick-fil-a whatever and then
he's like okay in and out
i'm like okay cool i'll get in and out
um and then he's giving me his order and
i'm like oh you know they have grilled
onions too because oh my god i know you
like relent grilled onions but you never
really order it and he goes oh yeah i
like uh i would prefer fresh onions over
grilled and then i just made my little
like comment like to myself not trying
to influence him but i still like said
it which was like
okay just like it kind of like smells
more like
your breath smell more like if it's
it's up and then i'm not gonna want to
kiss you
but like i did just mention that and
obviously like he was like oh okay then
just get grilled onions and i'm like no
i'm not going to get girl yeah you guys
do that yeah constantly you do that
yesterday too i was like
what are you saying there what happened
yesterday what was it yesterday where
tiff was saying like oh i thought it was
this thing in case he's like okay we'll
find it if you want that and then
tip was like no i you don't have to
it was about the episode because he was
uh editing this upcoming
way it was about saying lines yeah yeah
all i was trying to find out is like
well usually it's ready by friday but
now it's saturday so i'm like oh i was
just wondering like what's your plan and
but then the way it came out he was like
yeah i know i gotta work on it i know
you're telling me to get my work done i
know i need to do it
she's like no i'm just asking when
you're going to do it like i know i need
to do it yeah
i'm like oh [ __ ] like like
i'm just going to say this
yeah yeah do you think it was maybe your
tone
probably you know that's his biggest
thing
is my tone my tone people
speaking different languages too like
because for the longest time okay so for
example there's just one off the top of
my head but um i would call steve
sensitive and i didn't mean it in a bad
way i was just like oh you're sensitive
because he would pick up other people's
feelings or like if i made a comment or
like someone did something he would like
have a stronger emotional reaction
than i was used to in other partners and
and i didn't mean it as a bad thing i'm
sensitive too lack of a better word yeah
but he
perceives sensitive as being like
weak and like overly emotional and stuff
and i'm like no i don't mean like you're
an empath empathetic yeah and and so he
didn't it took him a while to to learn
that when i say sensitive it means that
and so i kind of had to adjust my
vocabulary and sometimes it's just as
simple as that as like learning what
words trigger your partner differently
yeah and so like the what you're trying
to communicate is like oh i just need an
eta yeah and he was like oh she's on me
about getting my work done yeah she he
just kept hearing the same thing even
though you thought you were very clear
i mean in my own head i was changing the
way i was communicating that phrase that
but then i would still get the same
response from him he's like yeah i know
i'll work on it i'm like i'm not telling
you
it seemed like you probably had that
argument before where you were like
shouldn't you be getting this done and
he's like yeah i guess so yeah i'll work
on it but then now this time you don't
want to be telling him what to do so
you're like oh isn't that due and then
you like you're like wait i'm not gonna
do this again
but he's just like i know what you
really want to say because we've had
this argument before now you're acting
like you're not telling me what to do
when you really want to tell me what to
do yeah and then that part and then that
gets me upset because i'm like don't put
words in my mouth i wasn't saying i'm
working on it i'm trying to change yeah
you're like i really don't want to tell
you what to do i just found myself in
this place again i know
oh so that's why we're working on yeah
and then and then yeah like pointing out
the fact that like i have
i have played a role in having that
behavior come out if that's his initial
reaction to you then it's probably like
that environment was created not that
it's a bad environment but just
that he's expecting that to be who what
you're doing yeah no for sure and then
it gets really frustrating too because
then i think about like the early like
the beginning of the relationship like i
wasn't
i like i don't think i was doing those
things to have that behavior come out of
him and then later he would just tell me
like oh i just thought like this is what
you wanted from me and i'm like
i got catfished into this relationship
like what like no like you
you could have just shown me who you
really were instead of being afraid that
i was going to reject you even though i
don't know what i did to make you feel
like i was going to reject you but
yeah like that's the stuff that we were
like preemptively accommodating yes
right xu is going to be expected
and it could be a learned behavior too
right like because we know ourselves and
we're like okay well the way that i was
in this past relationship and showing
them my real self like was a huge turn
off to them i don't want this to be a
turn off to you right so i'm gonna not
not that i'm gonna disguise it or not be
myself i'm just not going to do like
mach 12 give you that level of behavior
kind of thing yeah like i don't want to
do make the same mistake right in my
last relationship even though this is a
whole different person but it feels
small
to you it would feel false because
you're like well that's not but that's
not who you are right exactly so to back
to this like um saying like not bringing
things up right away um
what do you so jess what do you do with
your partner now cause you've been with
your girlfriend for a over a year now
like almost two almost two years almost
two years yeah
amazing congratulations thank you so
much when last time she was on the show
you guys had just started yeah a few
months and i just got out of divorce
yeah yeah it was very super dramatic um
what uh what how do you approach the
subject of like if something's bothering
you i have to tell you i'm not a good
communicator i'm really not a good
communicator laci is the world's best
communicator and it's because
she's very self-aware and she's i got
the best we say this all the time like
she's the best version of me and i have
the best version of her but i'm not one
i don't like i'm accommodating i um not
in the ways that i used to be when i was
younger but i'm definitely like
i don't care what we eat for dinner yeah
and if she cares then i just want her to
tell me what she wants to have because i
really don't care like i'll eat anything
i just don't want salad
so and we do fitness so it's usually a
salad which is totally fine um but again
i don't really care and then this is me
being like hashtag accomplishments
but i like really love sally um
but she'll force me to communicate yeah
because there's so many breakdowns in
communication in a relationship where
and we're coming out of covid so we're
just now jumping into the world where
we're having to see people and go out
and do things so there is a you know we
were in our own little bubble so like
that breakdown of communication isn't
necessarily her not being communicative
or me not communicating on my how i'm
feeling it's like we haven't been placed
in this situation before and we're lazy
totally my insecurities and this is the
thing too you bring so much [ __ ] and
baggage to every relationship but a lot
of times i have to realize that it's
nothing she's doing i'm being triggered
like something and i come from like a
survivor point of view so for me
i trust her so much with my life that if
there's one little thing that i feel
like is a breakdown in communication i
absolutely will feel like i'm not i
can't trust her and then i then i shut
down and then there she'll she'll force
me to talk about it because i need
someone to talk about it is so good and
catching that early in the relationship
is great because you need that
foundation
to set the precedent of like hey when
there's something wrong we talk about it
immediately totally and this is what i
expect from you and this is what you
expect from me and let's just be honest
about it so knowing that you're
not good at doing that do you ever try
to think like oh this is bothering me
like i need to say this before she has
to pull it out of me have you tried that
i do and i try to say it in a way that
doesn't feel upsetting because for me
it's tone like i don't get hurt i think
she wouldn't care what your tone is yeah
i feel like she really doesn't probably
wouldn't care what your tone is when
i've yelled before she just backs away
slowly and starts shutting the windows
because neighbors and she just holds the
space
because my tone is like i'm like but i'm
hurt because of this and it
automatically goes yeah
i can't hear my tongue i can't hear you
it's one of the biggest things he's like
stop yelling i'm like you're screaming
i'm not yelling it's just coming i have
this emotion it's just making my balls
you're making me yell it's because of
you that i'm doing this so because you
go straight to that you don't even want
to say anything at all is that what's
happening so you make her pull it out of
you sometimes it's they're fighting over
dinner like she doesn't want a salad so
she's gonna order something else she's
gonna come to her door and she would
order from doordash thank you doordash
for sponsoring this episode doordash
connects you with the restaurants you
love right now and right to your door
and now you can get the grocery
essentials you need with doordash too
you can get drinks snacks and other
household items delivered in under an
hour so you don't have to fight about
what to eat or what to get or you know
if you need toilet paper just hit up
doordash really quick and then you can
get back to your argument
makes it really easy for you to get back
to your argument yeah yeah
like you want a salad and you want to
say how much got you got you two
different places two different places
yeah ordering is super easy you open the
doordash app you choose what you want
from where you want so your items will
be left safely outside your door with
the contactless delivery drop-off
setting
they have over 300 000 partners in the
u.s puerto rico canada and australia so
you can support your neighborhood
go-to's or hit up your favorite national
restaurants like popeyes chipotle and
cheesecake factory cheesecake factory i
love chipotle yeah it's so delicious so
for a limited time our listeners can get
25 off and zero delivery fees on their
first order of 15 or more when you
download the doordash app and enter code
mood that's 25 off up to 10 value and
zero delivery fees on your first order
when you download the doordash app in
the app store and enter code mode don't
forget that's code mood for 25 off your
first order with doordash subject to
change terms apply yes and then our
second sponsor for this episode is a
great one actually it's talk space as
the year ends another holiday season is
upon us for many of us that means travel
and family and you know family could be
a real problem can cause you to see it
they're problematic
not only is the traveling part like
stressful especially right now with the
time that we're in but then also
traveling with family maybe you haven't
seen them in a long time maybe that
argument that you had two years ago that
you've been putting off because of a
pandemic is gonna come to light this
time because you're finally seeing them
at christmas
uh-oh
maybe you should go into that talk
already having discussed it with a
therapist tis the season to be jolly but
sometimes it doesn't feel that way and
that's okay ease some of the burdens as
the holidays can bring with talkspace
online therapy it's the number one
online therapy platform there's
thousands of licensed therapists
available for you to match with across
dozens of special specialties including
anxiety depression relationships and
more talkspace is ready to help you
start feeling better with a single
message
talkspace works around your schedule at
your convenience with live video
sessions and unlimited messages with
your dedicated therapist you can set
goals with your therapist and develop
techniques to cope in difficult times
like these holidays talkspace offers
individual therapy couples therapy and
medication prescription services so if
you need a little support to help you
through the end of the year i want to
start building towards a better upcoming
year talkspace is here to help match
with a licensed therapist when you go to
talkspace.com and get 100 off your first
month with the promo code mood that's
100 off when you use code mood at
talkspace.com
mm-hmm i think everybody needs therapy
everybody does this you don't even know
the things that make you think though
and feel the way you do until you go
have a someone dissect you to be
therapized and i have to just to answer
your question really quickly jess i
honestly think for me it's um i never
was forced to manage my emotions or even
identify them for that matter so i would
just i was in like mom mode like just
make the money pay the bills take care
of the babies survive i relate so hard
to everything that's coming out of your
mouth right now that i just i kind of
suppressed my emotions and they went
into my big toe which was very swollen
it's like
big toes holding in 40 years of life and
loving
that big toe
but it's in a very cute very cute
skin you would never know you would
never know but now that i um you know
you know you're in a mature relationship
and you're maturing yourself when you
can you can manage your emotions you can
identify them and sometimes i don't even
know what's bothering me she'll just be
like you're being you're something
changed on your face you're being silent
what is that and then i i can really
like sit with it and think about it be
like oh yeah it's that thing and then we
can talk about it yeah because um like i
like i said i relate so hard to what
you're saying but i
tend to like the little thing that i
think i'm mad at i will grab on to that
and and then i don't recognize my tone
either and i i can't for the [ __ ]
there could be a gun in my head and i
can't change my [ __ ] tongue
and then he's cantonese he like it's a
language of tones
tone is huge for him so i will just
change my tone like a tiny bit because
i'm bothered about something that i
think it's the thing that i'm bothered
by and and then for some reason like i
just end up getting angry because then
he'll point it out and i'm like it's the
[ __ ] thing i already said it's the
thing and then is it always something
different like it's something bigger or
something that's been under the surface
that's why i'm going to therapy right
now girl yeah i'm like let's figure this
out therapist i'm always like girlfriend
you need to help me i don't know what
the [ __ ] this is
but it can't keep going like this he's
he's made so many amazing changes and
like he's grown so much in our
relationship i'm like i feel behind
help me yeah i'm like what do i do so
she has me journaling a lot of things
and like auditing or not auditing what
is it inventorying yeah like your
feelings like um like situations
where yeah it's that's been helpful so
we're also set in our ways people right
yeah the older you get like that
if you never had to rewire yourself or
you were never made to then you don't
even know that you've been programmed to
do that that you've been
doing that your whole life
especially after 30 or 40 years it's a
lot to unpack oh yeah and to be like
let's look at it sometimes you don't
want to pack you're like can we just put
that suitcase in the closet yeah i don't
have to look at it i don't want to talk
about it
it's heavy yeah
it's too heavy let's pretend it doesn't
exist yeah let's throw the suitcase away
all right so next item on this list here
that they wrote is a common relationship
killer
is when you label your partner the
source of all your happiness and joy
oh yeah that's that's too much
for one person no
yeah yeah no one is responsible for your
happiness but yeah because then they can
break your day and it's not and that's
not fair yeah for them um i actually had
an ex that did that where
um they just didn't have their own thing
going on so their whole life was about
like supporting me or like you know
whatever i needed he wanted to be there
and i'm like
first of all i feel a little smothered
second of all um if i didn't want him
around because i like a lot of alone
time he would take it really personally
and i'm like it's not personal at all
like steve knows he understands me
perfectly where i'm like i just need
like to be alone all day because i need
to recharge and i need to like i have
like a thousand thoughts in my head and
it's really hard for me to respond to
people because they're all getting
jumbled in like what he's saying it's
not like you're out doing something like
so fun without you just like at home
you're like just let me be in my office
for a few hours yes yeah and and this
person took it really really personally
and i we had so many talks about it but
it was really just because like
they didn't know how to create their own
happiness
and so they put it all on
one making me happy or being trying to
be my sole source of happiness when i'm
like no i'm happy from other things too
like it's not just you and then also
like
i had to be their sole source of
happiness and that's too much
yeah
i just can't i can't be that there all
the time
that happens too when you go into a
relationship and you're not a whole
person yeah when you're looking for
someone to complete you or to fix
something like we do have to realize
like i i'm definitely guilty of this
especially in my younger relationships
where i'm like oh like i don't have to
be a whole i mean no i don't think
there's any one who's perfect but i'm
like i don't even have to be a whole
person i can just be with this person
and they could be half a person and i
can be half a person together that's a
whole person i'm really good at math
yeah so i think
i think just recognizing that even is
like sometimes it's really good to just
be alone and to figure your [ __ ] out you
know yeah because when you're a whole
person and you're with a whole person it
creates something better than any of you
could create alone and two whole people
yeah yeah exactly
i think all of my relationships uh i got
into because i
was needing someone to make me happy
so that's probably why this this last
like a year that i've been alone has
been the first time where i've actually
felt happy alone and not like desperate
and scared and just depressed and like
wanting to die yeah
gina what the [ __ ] are you jess is being
vulnerable
she's like hi i'm very toasty turn me
over
stop being comedic relief you were on
the surface of the sun we totally get it
yeah
yeah
lots of sweat
out there do you feel like a part of it
was codependency like do you do you feel
like you're a co-dependent type of
person yeah because i'm definitely i
yeah i was guilty i mean i had terrible
terrible
parent my mom was a just terrible
terrible parent um just kind of
abandoned me sort of my dad came in
later and kind of tried to fill the void
and take care of me a little bit but
because they were divorced and she did
such a terrible job the first like eight
years that you know like he he came in
but he's also just a man a lot of men
especially older generations aren't very
emotionally available emotionally
intelligent um so he did the best he
could by just being there but like just
the emotional needs were never ever met
like absolutely not and so i think every
single relationship i had like i 100
latched on to that person and expected
them to make me happy and if it didn't
happen then i was just distraught like i
mean i could be
i was i was always going between a state
of limerence which i don't know if you
know what that means it's like
vocab words new vocab word vocabulary
is just like this obsessive kind of like
you're in this fantasy world it's just
it's mainly a very obsessive state of
like being in love with this person and
like really exercising every situation
yeah so it would be that and then until
i would get with the person and then i
would kind of like try to keep that
alive and then like reality would kind
of hit and then i would just be so
depressed because like the person is not
what i thought they were or
um you know just they were just very
toxic too and i was just very
co-dependent on people that had the same
pattern as my mom like they were
unavailable for some reason either they
were an alcoholic or drug addict like my
mom was or they were a workaholic or
they were they were just unavailable for
some reason so i kept
doing the same thing like my happiness
was based on making that person love me
so that it completes the cycle of like i
never got it from my mom right yeah
that's how you
process love as a child so you were
familiar with that mm-hmm yeah yeah
definitely definitely all of my
relationships i was not a whole person
before i went into them and they were
all not great i mean like my last one
was five years and it wasn't like
terrible nothing catastrophic happened
it wasn't abusive or anything like that
but it was just
not it wasn't good either i mean it
wasn't good for either of us it wasn't
great um but then i did have some that
were just very very like mentally abused
and i've never been physically abused
because i'm like a hard [ __ ] but like
i've had some mentally abusive ones that
yeah just so bad and and it hurt me so
much so yeah and and i just
now that i've been able to get out of
that and spend a whole year alone and
like enjoy myself and love myself and be
comfortable and almost like not want
anyone to come in because that's scary
because i don't trust myself yet but i
just really would love to tell anyone
that because i know so many people are
doing the same path yeah it's a pattern
because if you don't break it you have
to consciously like make it take a break
and assess yourself like you really
really like very sexy i would hear that
all the time like you you have to be
happy first and i would think like okay
yeah cool like you know i like my job
like whatever like i'm happy like like
just give me a happy little [ __ ]
but i never really was like i never
really i if until you're okay with being
like okay i could die alone like i could
just literally i'll live with cats like
i'll 40 years can go by it's okay like
until you can really truly believe that
i don't think you're actually a whole
person yeah agreed and kind of to
nikki's point like when you rely on
someone for your soul happiness you're
also giving them the power to completely
destroy yeah i mean so much so much of
my uh like i was trying to study for
this or i was trying to do that like it
would just be so [ __ ] like i couldn't
get anything done like my plans were
ruined like i just yeah i lost so much
time and effort that i could have been
spending on my career on different
things like that so yeah i say that to
my girlfriends all the time when they're
going through something i'm like you
just have to re you have to
grab your power and like regain it and
it doesn't mean anything other than like
being happy alone like we have to be
able to be happy alone and be able to
sit alone
um but i understand like that is
[ __ ] hard yeah easier said than done
so much easier said than done but you're
doing the work it's a different kind of
power yeah yeah like you'll never know
the power until you've done it and
that's your power and you're doing the
work and you'll know it's easier to spot
when the right person comes along
because everyone else just feels like
they're sucking from you like they're
like draining what you've just built and
then the right person feels like they're
adding to it they'll spark you up yeah
they'll let you up yeah that's that's
all great stuff i'm like sitting here
listening
because i'm like i have been in a
relationship since i was 16. i've been
in a lot of relationships and i've been
married twice so i feel like
dr phil
like i've only been single for two
minutes
yeah so i'm like i've never experienced
that yeah i think but then that's why i
felt like it got to a pretty good place
when i did that solo trip for my
birthday and i was like i've just i've
never experienced being alone i want to
know what it's like and i absolutely
loved it like being having a
less than a week by myself obviously the
destination was yeah that made it a lot
better that's not real life yeah of
course not um but i mean that's the only
tiny little taste of that that i've ever
gotten in my whole life yeah and i'm
just like that that felt like heaven
like whoa this is cool like in the past
i could never sit in a room like by
myself silence i love driving in silence
now and like i like i like like calmness
and in the past silence would hurt my
ears and it was like oh my god this is
like it was it was definitely it was
just like i can't [ __ ] sit with
myself and now i'm like oh
i'm cool can i just tell you earlier you
were saying everything that you were
saying that i was saying was landing on
you not everything she's saying is
laying on me i went to london to shoot a
show for a month and i was completely
alone yeah lisa didn't come with me
because she would have been quarantined
and karen my daughter had work and a
life of her own
but
stiff i've never had
to take i've never been alone and i've
always had to take care of someone so i
love taking care of someone am i either
taking care of my daughter or i'm taking
care of our dog or i'm taking care of my
girlfriend
i've never had to just take care of
myself so when i was alone i was like
wow like what do i i don't even know
what to do like yeah i'm a reader now
yeah she's a reader folks i read i was
taking care of my skin i was like wait
you did it before you [ __ ]
there was like
i did it five times instead of three it
was three hours a night instead of two
and i was like figuring out like just
sitting with that unsettling feeling of
being alone and like having no one else
to take care of it i think a lot of that
too is women like we do that because
especially when you're a mom we have
that mom guilt where it's like there's
no way i can't be taking time out for
myself right now yeah they need isaac
needs something yeah like baby needs
something like who what someone needs
something when it's just like
it's okay we have to take care of
ourselves first like oh yeah i have
needs to have you yeah that's okay yeah
it's like oh yeah yeah did you feel a
person did you feel anything negative
come up in that week or did you feel
anxiety come up like it was finally or
it wasn't sorry it was it was pretty
crazy i was really anxious at first
because i'm like how am i going to fill
up my time and then i honestly thought
of nikki because in quarantine she
picked up like every habit and this is
like 75 yeah she became like a painter
and a
drawer player she did real estate
um
and i was like there's got to be
something like what what is what is my
one thing and for me it was it was
reading and like just being
quiet yeah it was so weird just being
quiet yeah
i actually took a book to my trip too
but i couldn't focus but it's because
the silence can be definitely yeah um
no the view is just really distracting
like a really beautiful woman bora bora
[ __ ] i can't [ __ ] focus like this is
gorgeous
i was like this is the most amount of
instagram stories i've ever seen from
jess she was in london yeah
you like head to toe gorgeous because
you're probably like doing your hair
like extra yeah yeah yeah
i'll be camera ready so i was like oh
i'm going to take advantage of your skin
was glow and pop
it's never not but like it was extra
thank you
yeah there's also no sun in london with
the time that i was there and i don't
know if you guys are like this
dude
the sun hates the weather affects me
great
i can't handle overcast at all i
actually don't like it when it's
overcast i'm just like joke because i
get sunburned so easily but i do love
the sun but yeah my therapist is like
you're fair yeah you're very fair my
therapist is actually trying to figure
out like what's wrong because i've i'm
like i've only met like two people that
are like this where i know if it's
overcast even before i look outside
because i feel this impending sense of
doom like we're all gonna die and life
is pointless and nothing makes sense and
um and so like people always said like
oh something happened to you when it was
overcast in your childhood i'm like i
can't think of any specific event that
happened to me
but like my therapist is like no it was
just that general like i grew up in
santa barbara and it's on by the beach
and so that marine layer was always
there like until the afternoon and it
would burn off yeah and i was very
lonely as a child like alone like 100
alone all the time
in that way of like
not alone but lonely like there's a
difference because i like being alone
but i don't like being lonely right and
like it was like i want to interact with
people and there's no one to interact
with and like sometimes i would go home
and feel like um like i could just
disappear and nobody would notice and so
like she's like that's that whole era of
time comes back when it's overcast
one event yeah and it's like this like
pointless like what's the point of me
being here because like nobody even
knows like that i'm here
i feel that way about night time like i
get really depressed oh yeah yeah i
could see that yeah nighttime feels does
feel very lonely for me i'm like if it
just rain like if you're going to rain
rain if you're gonna be gloomy
it's raining rain
with winter gloom because it's winter
and it's like holidays like holidays
yeah you need to light a candle yeah
yeah and like cozy
when's that white sky where it's like
reflective it's like a bounce board and
it's like a fluorescent curtain
you gotta go back under a bed and
underneath my bed and going back to bed
yeah just rain yeah
rain little [ __ ] weather just make a
decision
all right next one on this list uh
it's a common relationship mistake when
you get so comfortable in a relationship
that you take it or the other person for
granted oh yeah i feel like that one
happens granted i feel like that's why
people say seven year rich right yeah
that's now moving to like ten years like
you've all been in long relationships
yeah i feel like i already know the
answer you don't have enough i've never
had seven years yeah i mean i was
worried about i was like because
everyone was telling me like just wait
seven years
yeah and i'm like i literally want to
jump his bones all the time like i have
no
whatsoever itch but we were always very
conscious about it i think that like
from the beginning we were like we never
want to get sick of each other we never
want this feeling to end so any time
like if you're ever upset it was that
communication thing like nipping it in
the bud because both of us had baggage
when we entered and we were fighting a
lot and we
loved our time together but then we
couldn't figure out what we kept
fighting and so nipping that all in the
butt in the in the very beginning and
just knowing that like this is my person
like if they need me i'm there like if
something i'm doing is upsetting let's
get to the bottom of it and i i've never
felt more understood and each year we
find out more about each other and i
think there's always something left to
discover so it doesn't get old you know
and also you guys have a lot of respect
for each other and i think something
that respect is massive and admiration i
think when you lose admiration for a
person that you're with you kind of do
you lose a little bit of respect for
them because if you think about like
what drew you to him and what drew you
to casey like a big part of that is like
they're really cool yeah i admire them
as a person and they're doing something
awesome so when that person loses their
own spark you kind of it's that's really
that's something that's really grapple
with that can happen really quickly with
the resentment eroding yeah like
resentment at least in previous
relationships um it was like they're
acting fine but i still i'm not
attracted to as attracted to them as i
was in the beginning because as i think
subconsciously like all the [ __ ] up
things that they did early in the
relationship just like
didn't go away like because it built up
and it was just too strong and it didn't
unpack that and it just broke the like
the magic feeling you know and i just
never got it back and so
yeah with steve it's like i never want
this to end and and the magic stays and
i'm not saying like i know everything
because obviously i don't know what
happens at 10 years i don't know like
anything can happen but i think that
this is the healthiest relationship i've
ever been in and if i could just speak
from
finding this healthy place it's like
definitely all of these things are 100
percent true nipping it in the bud with
so that resentment doesn't build um not
making them your primary source of
happiness like we he is my he's
the thing that makes me the most happy
but it's i don't rely on him
yeah source of happiness you guys also
did a good thing and you didn't
self-fulfill a prophecy because
sometimes we do that i don't know if you
read a book when you were when you were
you're pregnant but i read what to
expect when you're expecting so at four
months when they're like you're gonna be
nauseous
if i hadn't maybe read that i made it i
might have been okay but now i was like
oh yeah i'm not a little nauseous oh and
you this your body may react weirdly to
this and i'm like oh my body is reacting
weirdly to this oddly enough like i
don't like bananas anymore yeah like
whatever that thing is and it's just
yeah so the seven year itch is like
hearing oh yeah and then you're like oh
you have a problem and then you're like
okay i'm looking for it yeah i'm looking
for that thing yeah he is less
attractive when he does this one thing
that's really annoying
and it's communication you've been
together for so long it's like okay how
many how much more can i we talk about i
know everything about you you know
everything about me and it's that
constant chasing and dating and like
having admiration and having respect oh
okay so just tools for this because
you're maybe like how do you not lose
that um so like we love going to new
places together that neither of us have
been memories yeah so it's like you're
constantly discovering you're
discovering the a new place but you're
also getting to hear a fresh take on
what they think about it and then you
get to share your take and mostly
they're similar but sometimes they're
different and now you're learning new
things about him exactly and so there's
always something left to discover and he
surely does too that's what we're doing
yeah traveling so i guess you know that
about your heart
people that start to
take things for granted it's like you
assume you already know everything about
that person and you're so you're not
even looking at them
you're just like i know that like sky's
blue trees green
person my wife is my wife she's my
person uh the tv is over there like i
don't even have to look like i don't
even i don't have to interact i already
know i i'm not looking at the tree i'm
that's my friend because i don't even
[ __ ] care because i already know
everything there's nothing new out there
and there is always something new and
it's so sad that like
i think we do lose it through like
technology and like through time of this
connection yeah assuming that things are
always they're never changing nothing's
new and it seems worse now too because
we have a an app that we can download
that will connect you with a whole bunch
of new exciting people millions of them
yeah so it's like it's going to say
scare is scary i thought you're going to
talk about this app that connects you
with your partner because we actually i
downloaded this app that will prompt up
questions and you and your partner can
answer them and then you get to know
them on a deeper level
and like things that like you didn't
think that or that you thought because
sometimes they'll have quizzes on it too
or is it that we're not really strangers
no it's uh it's called paired oh okay
that's the one that we have
yeah they score oh
oh i like that well not i mean it's like
newlyweds but with each other yeah
exactly
seven years later there'll be quizzes
where it's like oh i totally cause then
they'll tell you like how would casey
answer this question and then he'll
answer it so then it'll be an answer but
then i'll answer it i'm like oh he'll
totally say this and then he ends up
saying something else i'm like what the
and then we'll talk about it and then
like get to know his like thought
process he's surprised there's a
connection yeah yeah exactly the element
of surprise i think is something that
you should always have and it's sexy
yeah yeah and surprise me yeah yeah like
one time i asked i like called steve
from upstairs to help me clean something
in the bedroom and he showed up and i
was in a french maid outfit and like he
was not expecting that he was surprised
and it's like i've never done that since
like yeah just you never know
yeah yeah
mostly sweatpants but you know sometimes
it's a french tomato french meat i
wanted to give a shout out to our
sponsor today hellofresh hellofresh is a
service that i've been using for a long
time now quite a few years and i love it
it makes it so easy to cook your
favorite meals meals that maybe you
didn't even know were your favorite
meals until after you cooked them i've
learned so many new meals from
hellofresh and not only are they
delicious but also
you can recreate these meals on your own
so you kind of like learn a new recipe
as you go and they're all so good they
give you the freshest ingredients to
work with and then they have the recipe
all prepared you can choose what kind of
diet you want too so for example i don't
eat meat so they have a vegetarian one
there's a meat eaters one there's all
kinds of ones just check it out you know
pick your diet and you can go with it
and they'll give you the best recipes uh
to make with it but you know the
holidays can be hectic hellofresh keeps
things simple with recipes that cut back
on meal prep and clean up so you spend
less time in the kitchen and more
quality time with your friends and
family they offer 50 menu and market
items to choose from every week
including vegetarian like i said calorie
smart gourmet plenty of variety and they
have ingredients that travel from the
farm to your front door within a week so
you get the convenience without skimping
on the quality plus you skip trips to
the grocery store and avoid the the long
holiday lines um all of these recipes
too you can make them really fast i
think they're all like 30 minutes long
anyway i've really enjoyed every single
meal that i've made from hellofresh and
that's why hellofresh is america's
number one meal kit so go to
hellofresh.com big mood 14 and use code
big mood 14 for up to 14 free meals and
three free gifts
geez i like i like free you get three
free gifts hellofresh.com bigmood14 do
it
okay next one on the list this one says
not listening and being defensive when
your partner is upset about something
you do really listen to them resist the
urge to always defend yourself yeah take
a pause evaluate and try to understand
how something is making them feel that's
guilty absolutely i'm [ __ ] guilty i'm
like what do you mean i did this wrong
but it's because you're defensive you're
being defensive right right right right
right like i'm [ __ ] guilty where does
both people just come from
the what where does the defensiveness
come from because i for sure like can
never be wrong about anything do you
feel like it comes from a place of you
feel like you're not being heard though
you're like but you're hurt because you
think i did something but i didn't do
anything therefore
you think you're hurt but you're
actually hurting me because i didn't
hurt you yeah personally
yeah i feel like it's because i always
try to think hard to do a good job like
i like will go out of my way to try to
do the best job
so i do it's like when you say that i
hurt you and i wasn't trying to i didn't
mean to i get really like wait no i like
that's not what i meant like i wasn't
like yeah i was it was i said it because
of this thing that happened because i
would never try to hurt you so
like
like just want them to know i guess i
just want them to know that i'm always
trying to do the best job not to hurt
them and so i feel like i failed yeah i
feel like i failed at that and it's
intentions i like i really tried lacy
does this thing where
i've i've people wouldn't know this
about me but i'm actually very sensitive
and but it's because i have like a tough
exterior don't tell her secret stuff and
buff and rub
but um something will happen and i will
internalize and i'll be and i will take
it personally and like talking about
that and she'll just say i i hear you
and this is where i was coming from so
me just knowing what her intentions were
knowing that it wasn't to hurt me but i
it was hurtful
and just her acknowledging that yeah
feels so good because then you're not
being shut down i'm so used to being
shut down yeah why are you mad why are
you angry now you're being crazy yeah
just call a woman crazy and see what
happens
currently like right now is what i'm
working on uh with my therapist is
learning how to validate
emotions first because i struggle so
hard with that with casey and with isaac
and especially right now isaac being
like full-blown teenager hormones raging
and then like he's just coming at me
with some attitude and i'm like you
disrespected me little boy like you
better [ __ ] check yourself and but
then he's upset because of this other
thing and then i i'm like you're not
acknowledging that you're just like
talking about the
not the thing exactly and then i just
i'm only focused on how i felt about it
and i'm like [ __ ] and so that was one of
the things that my therapist had do had
me do like an inventory on it's like
what are the times that you felt like
you didn't validate him and like what
what are the times that you felt like he
didn't feel like you might have made him
feel not heard because he's expressed
that to me sometimes where it's like
yeah i just feel like you don't listen
to me and i'm like oh [ __ ] i don't [ __ ]
let me work on this [ __ ] let me write
this down but yeah it's like
it's hard it's hard so hard
communication is hard you know what
though i feel like the more people do it
to you like for you like where they
validate your feelings the more you want
to do it for them because steve and i
were both really stubborn people and
defensive people when we first started
dating and
not to keep talking about but like we
learned a lot from this like i love all
of these they're all like exactly like
the
the things to work on yeah um and he is
so he has
been so good about like if i get upset
about something he did he used to you
know because he's just like me he wants
to do a good job and so he's getting
defensive but now he goes like okay i
hear you like it's like just what you
were saying about lacey and it even just
that is so disarming and it makes me
feel like
oh okay like hear me
and i was gonna leave i have my suitcase
my three things i'm out of here keep
moving my cats yeah i got this cat okay
you take jokes yeah
angrily but you're going to stop me at
some point
right that's funny she always wants to
stop true though like with casey going
into therapy and stuff like and then now
he knows how to do that so well i gotta
like congratulate you yeah i've seen a
huge change in the energy that you guys
have yeah because like he's so like it's
a [ __ ] radical change that seven year
itch we talked about earlier for us it
was like okay it's seven years i'm sick
of this [ __ ] something needs to change
and then he felt the same way and then
we went to marriage therapy counseling
whatever and then he really learned all
these tools and learned how to apply
them i'm like holy [ __ ] i gotta catch up
because you're doing great so he knows
how to like validate and he knows how to
listen
a lot better than before like a [ __ ]
mile is better than before and and in
the past he would immediately get
defensive and get mad at me for pointing
something out yeah that he did that
upset me and and then like that would go
like downhill like so like the problem
was like this bad and like it would go
here based off of like how it was
handled but then now it doesn't get
there anymore it's just like because you
can break it down yeah and you'd be like
oh that's bothering you well why is that
bothering you yeah that's not what i
meant it breaks it where both partners
now want to listen to each other because
if one person goes i hear you then now
the other person's like oh okay i want
to hear you too well i'm working on that
okay i am the one now working on being
the one that's like okay i don't have to
be defensive anymore because i'm just so
like but you hurt me like i'm angry at
this and he's like i hear you i that's
not my intention i wasn't trying to do
that i'm like but you did
so like [ __ ] i got it don't hurt it's
like my pride like yeah you go [ __ ] and
it's like
but ultimately like in those situations
it's like well what could he possibly
say to make it not hurt anymore because
he's saying all the right things it's
like now you just have to like
those feelings just have to dissipate
but
it like yeah it comes down to like at
least knowing your partner is
validating you and trying to understand
and also apologizing like hey i'm sorry
i would never want to hurt you yeah um i
understand how you why you would feel
that way this is where i was coming from
yeah this is where i was coming from i
did not mean to do that
yeah also like all of that is what is
needed to get to at least to get me to
like a more like neutral place but then
sometimes because obviously he's not
going to flip a switch and be perfect
right yeah and like some of the old
habits will come in where it's like well
i'm sorry
and then like that's it and i'm like
rage
but that's also like how we cope right
we're so used to that coping and it
worked for so long and it's just not
working anymore
so like at least you're you know that
it's not work you're that coping is not
working for you anymore and that it's
just it's hurting you guys
but that's that's a hard we are
creatures of habit pattern and so it
does take a long time to like in many
situations to
change change it yeah and like it feels
good though because now like when when
he comes to me with something and i'm
like i'm so sorry you know i understand
it it feels good to
give that back and to also like
be an equally supportive partner and be
like be there for him now we're on the
same team we're gonna find the problem
together and solve it together instead
of like we're fighting each other we're
at war with each other and because you
want him to be happy like you want him
to be happy he wants you to be happy i
think we
run the risk of breakup and divorce when
you genuinely don't care about the other
person's happiness yeah like that you
just want to win definitely
when like the you winning and you being
right
is more important than
just that letting them be happy then
yeah that's very problematic yeah i was
just sitting here thinking like isn't it
weird just in a macro level that we have
to constantly
re-establish that we're on the same team
and it's just like that we
to constantly make adjustments it's like
but we're together like i wouldn't just
hurt you yeah like why right now this
morning did you wake up and think that i
meant that to hurt you you know isn't it
that person is always maybe gonna [ __ ]
me over yeah and it's feeling safe like
i don't know if this is how you feel
this is definitely how i feel i've never
had i've never felt safe from a very
young age i've had to protect myself and
um i've been abandoned and it's been
horrible so if you have to protect
yourself and you're the only person
who's going to protect you from a young
age you kind of go into adulthood
feeling that way so then when you
finally trust someone the instance that
they you feel like that trust is broken
you feel unsafe you're like i knew it
wasn't feeling safe yeah the world is
unsafe and you start to like shut down
and break break down and like that's
something that i've had to
relearn literally it's like i could have
said those words yeah you two are very
similar past and very very similar yeah
yeah
it's trauma it's trauma and it's like
coping and it's relearning and
constantly adjusting like wow man is it
hard to human oh yeah it's so much work
it's a lot of work i didn't ask for this
[ __ ] but that's why in a healthy
partnership i feel like you are helping
each other like work through your own
problems like yes you each had traumas
and then you're each like in a healthy
way helping each other each time you
work through something and you release
that can i tell you i was at a birth at
a bridal shower the other day and i was
talking to this woman who was married to
her wife for 16 years and she wanted me
she wanted to know from me what i
thought marriage was and i thought oh
yeah marriage is about being on the same
team and you're supporting each other
and you have this life partner and she's
like honestly what i've learned is that
marriage is about we all have our
traumas and it's like how can we unpack
them because sometimes that trauma won't
come up for 20 years so now you're
together you've been married 35 years
and you're like my partner is changing
when it's really it could be this
triggered trauma that's coming up that
now you both have to work through but we
just live in the age where like divorce
is easy and like we don't have to work
through things anymore i've been
divorced twice so i know how easy it is
to back out of something yeah i think
with when it comes to that it's like
if both parties are on the same page of
wanting to work through it together then
cool but if one person's just not in it
yeah then
you have to walk away or like yeah there
comes to there has to come to a breaking
point at some point because you can't
sacrifice your own happiness that's what
it is and when you're not worried about
the other person's happiness where it's
like that's fine that's how you feel but
i genuinely this is me this is me yeah
and i'm not gonna change to make you
happier exactly then it's oh yeah it's
like oh it's a compromise situation so
there's no one what you want here yeah
okay i feel therapized guys yeah
who's the first to cry come on
i saw you getting close yeah
[Music]
all right so this is gonna be the last
one from this list but there's more if
you guys are curious you can check out
the link in the description it's pretty
good but this one says stop hiding
things from each other especially
keeping things from each other for their
own good not only do they not know
everything you kept a secret and now you
have developed trust issues in your
partner if you are doing something or
have a relationship that you don't want
your partner to know about it that's a
huge red flag what is that
what would you be doing that you're not
saying that's what i mean
it's probably because it's not
the relationship
yeah yeah or it could just be um
something that can affect the
relationship but you think it's your own
thing and that your partner doesn't need
to know about it like for example like i
don't know having like alcoholism or
something and like but they you don't
want them to know that they're they're
alcoholic
you gotta handle they don't need to know
about it you're gonna like it yourself
yeah exactly like smokers or whatever
they'll buy that from their relationship
that could be like one example or
another it's like a secret just anything
that you don't want to tell your partner
that should be a reflection to you that
like something exciting because yeah if
you don't want to tell someone there's a
reason why you don't want to tell
someone yeah and is it is it either that
it's wrong you're doing it or is it that
you're with someone who doesn't just
accept you
and it's not like a bad thing like maybe
it's not a bad habit but like they
wouldn't accept you you know because it
so they're not going to accept all of
you yeah yeah that seems weird but i
don't know
are people allowed to have secrets
though like our just as a human as an
individual am i do i have do i get some
autonomy do i get some of just me where
you don't you get 99 but i still get one
percent i feel like i think that's what
it is yeah it depends on what it is if
it's something i think it would if
that like if your partner knew it would
really hurt them or maybe even cause
them to
not want to be with you yeah maybe
that's like a too big of one i don't
know
i don't know i think that's hurting them
right like if it's not something that's
hurting them like there's you know
there's some traumas that i just will
not i can't bring up and it's not
because it's um it's a secret it feels
like it's a secret because you're not
sharing them you're not being open about
them um but i feel like in that case
it's not hurting my partner so
i feel like
for me that
i understand what you're saying um but
then the the way that i end up
processing that in my head is like well
because they're your life partner and
they're with you and you go through
issues and if there's something that
might happen like might trigger you and
they're they don't know how to be there
for you then i get it it isn't not
hurting them like because it's it's
hurting they don't know because it might
hurt it's hurting their relationship
because there's it's not fully out there
you can't fully be a partner and you're
you're not allowing them to fully
understand they're not fully disclosing
i guess this is the way i kind of
process that um and for me it's not just
it's not the disclosing part i'm cool
with disclosing part for me is details
like i don't need to break down every
single challenge
i don't i think that's something okay
yeah
yeah guys because i don't know like i
don't think secrets are good ever ever
for some people yeah revisiting details
of trauma is actually yeah harmful it's
very harmful right professional i agree
with you
yeah that i agree with yeah okay yeah
cause then like i was thinking too like
another example of like a type of secret
or something would be like maybe a type
of relationship that you have with
someone that you're you wouldn't want
your partner to know about even though
it's like innocent and nothing's going
on and it wouldn't hurt your like it's
not hurting your partner
like that is still something you're
keeping from them because with holding
information can feel is a lot it's like
a conscious lie it's not hurting them
now because they don't know but once
they find out yeah they're going to be
hurt
at your worst yeah why don't you just
tell me or texting your ex or something
like that yeah
okay that makes sense because when
you're reading that i'm like i don't
wait i'm so confused who why would you
lie about something yeah what would you
hold back that you things that you think
are are harmless or you're brushing them
off as harmless but your partner found
out i wouldn't i know he's jealous so i
can't tell him because i'm not doing
this he won't understand it's like it's
just gonna cause a whole thing like i'm
not doing anything so i'm just not going
to tell him yeah and then but like if
that [ __ ] comes out then you really
created a problem for sure definitely so
yeah definitely
well guys
we uh went through so many different
things here we hope you you guys that
are listening yeah i love this list who
would you just ask uh this is half of
reddit but
was it like psychology like
psychologists contributed because i feel
like these are very like
these are actually what you go through
in therapy yeah it's very specific yeah
also check out jess's everything like
she has a show coming out she can't talk
about it yet but follow her on instagram
and all these socials just underscore
lazama on instagram and any any and
justlyzama.com
and uh she has updates there all the
time so when it does come out you can go
check it out i'm going to launch it yeah
watch my show it's uk based i can say
that yeah
it's with um e4
and it's a teen mom show so i'll be
hosting
thank you i'm so i'm so ready to like
help you know shape young people's lives
so thank
you shape all of our lives yeah
please adopt all of us i will i love
being the internet's mom i love it no
and then guys get get um get excited
because
my own personal goal is to have jessa's
ammo come back multiple times
i love my time with you guys thank you
for having me yeah or having me i guess
this upcoming year because it's episodes
coming out in the end oh yeah at the end
of this year okay
yeah all right you're getting details
you know
yeah make sure to like this video
comment check out our the description
for all of our sponsors that's how you
can show support for the show and share
with your friends yeah share with your
friends and then comment down your own
common relationship mistakes that you
think should have been part of this list
that we didn't talk about
and have a discussion all right bye guys
bye
[Music]
so
[Music]
you